Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing Trolls World Tour's
hilarious deleted ending with the Bergens
Bridget and Gristle
plus 14 more amazing deleted scenes and songs
you never got to see!
As the credits roll on the final version of
Trolls World Tour, we get a fun dance party
and song that finishes with a cool cameo by
everyone's favourite Bergens, Bridget and
Gristle.
But there's an arguably even funnier post-credits
scene that we almost got:
"Poppy come quick!"
"Cloud Guy what is it?"
"I'm having a... a baby!"
These are the three Cloud babies we see riding
along with Cloud Guy and his girlfriend in
the credits of the final movie.
And, of course, the cut scene is also a fun
riff on how Guy Diamond gives birth to Tiny
Diamond.
"Poppy, come quick!
It's an emergency!"
"Guy Diamond, what's wrong?"
"I'm having a baby!"
The deleted credits scene continues in the
vein of a cheesy family-based TV sitcom complete
with canned laughter, as we see Cloud Guy
trying to take care of his kids.
♪ Love is to be in every moment.
♪
♪ La la la la laaa ♪
♪ Love is enjoying the passage of time ♪
♪ Love is living up on Cloud 9! ♪
"Mew."
"What the heck's this sack of garbage?"
"Yaaay!"
"Urgh.
No thank you!"
And that hilarious ending with Bridget and
Gristle watching the show on TV might well
have been another Bergen cameo, appearing
right at the very end of the credits, in addition
to the mid-credits scene we got in the final
movie:
"Aw, Grissy, I guess we're late to the party."
"Aw, balls!"
"Grissy."
"But who's gonna eat my cheese balls, babe?"
The first trailer for Trolls World Tour features
a scene cut from the final movie of Poppy
singing The Sound of Silence together with
the same weird and wonderful forest creatures
that accompanied her when she sang the song
in the first Trolls film.
According to the Trolls World Tour wiki, this
deleted scene of Barb crashing Poppy's song
was how the movie was originally going to
begin.
And instead of Barb's pet bat Debbie delivering
an invitation to Queen Poppy, this was going
to be how Poppy discovered that there were
other Troll tribes.
Cloud Guy had a relatively small part in Trolls
World Tour, just narrating the opening scene
and briefly dancing on stage with the other
Trolls at Barb's concert.
Originally though, there was a deleted scene
in which Poppy, Branch, Biggie and Dinkles
bump into him again.
"Cloud guy!"
"Cloud guy."
"Slappy!
Broppy pants.
Hey... fist bump?
Old time's sake?"
"No."
That would have been a call-back to when Cloud
Guy pranked Branch in the first movie:
"I'm gonna let you slide with a fist bump.
Shark attack!
Nom-nom-nom-nom.
Jellyfish!"
In the cut scene, Cloud Guy would have also
introduced us to his new girlfriend.
"Guys, this is...
Janet.
We're dating!
Janet and Cloud Guy, J-Loud Guy.
That's our couple name."
Janet does make a brief appearance in the
end credits of the final movie where the two
clouds already seem to be acquainted and give
each other engagement rings, which makes a
little more sense now we've seen this missing
moment.
"How long have you guys known each other?"
"Ten minutes.
And we're going to last forever!"
"Woh, slow your roll Romeo.
That seems a bit much this early."
"We'll talk about this later Honey Bunny."
"No we won't Angel Cake."
"Cheddar cheese."
"Sugar booger."
"Jane."
"Oh!
You didn't?"
"Yeah, I did!"
"Well that's it!
Relationship over."
"Fine, this was a bicycle meant for two Janet!
For two!"
Given that the pair split up in this deleted
clip, it seems that we were meant to interpret
the final movie's credits scene as them getting
back together.
By the way, during their break-up, we can
see how similar they are, when Janet uses
the kind of dramatic word fade that Cloud
Guy liked to use in the first movie.
"Janet and Cloud Guy were just doomed to fail.
Fail, fail, fail."
"Certain death, death, death, death, death...
Broppy fans would have probably enjoyed the
next part of this deleted scene also:
"But you guys were such a cute couple."
"Yeah, and we ruined it.
Guess we were just too different.
Hope that doesn't happen with you two."
"Oh no, no, it's not that...
See...
We're just friends...
We're not...
it's just...
just...
friends...
just friends.
He's not my boyfriend."
"Right."
But Cloud romances seem to move pretty quickly
in the Trolls world because Janet has a rebound
already set up with a thunderstorm cloud:
"Well time to move on..
winds are changing, yada, yada..
Besides my rebound's here.
"Rebound?"
"Are any of these guys bothering you?"
With Sheila B popped, the trolls hurtle towards
the ground below.
Fortunately though, Poppy finds some gum and
they blow bubbles that act as parachutes helping
them land safely.
"I swallowed my gum."
"Eww."
Next up is a mind-blowing deleted song that
Poppy and Branch sing together as they set
out their trip around the Troll kingdom on
the Sheila B balloon.
But just before we dive into that I want to
thank the sponsor of this video Full Sail
University.
If you've ever wondered about learning the
skills to break into the film or animation
business, but don't know where to begin,
check out Full Sail University whose graduate
students have landed jobs on award-winning
movies and TV shows including How To Train
Your Dragon, Toy Story 4 and Avengers: Endgame.
Full Sail's Film Bachelor's degree program
immerses you in the world of filmmaking from
every angle.
You'll gain practical experience while learning
what it's like to work on a film from start
to finish, giving you a feel for the role
each crew member plays in a production.
And the Computer Animation degree program
guides students through the same production
pipeline used in professional studios, from
storyboarding, sketching, and visual development
to modeling and character animation, and final
compositing.
These degrees are offered in an accelerated
format to get you into the field faster.
If you want to find out more about these film
programs and how to get started, visit FullSail.edu/FlicksAndTheCity
to learn more.
A fun song that was sadly cut from the movie
was a big musical number where Branch and
Hickory sang an ode to Poppy who they called
the "Queen of Pop".
♪ Following the Queen of Pop
Knowing that you won't give up ♪
This deleted song was storyboarded by DreamWorks
artist Jeremy Bernstein and is sung in a country-pop
crossover style.
♪ We're just a pair of fools
Who'll do anything for you ♪
A little bit of this original scene was kept
in the final movie when Hickory sings a short
country song to Branch accompanied by singing
river reeds, though in the final version,
the song he sings is Patsy Cline's I Fall
to Pieces.
The giant river eel-like creatures that swim
under the boat in this deleted scene also
appeared in unused Trolls World Tour concept
art of the trolls telling each other ghost
stories.
A great deleted scene with the movie's antagonist
sees Barb rocking up at an old diner in her
"World Destruction Tour" Anglerbus.
Inside the diner are groups of trolls whose
musical styles are no longer very popular
so they're sitting around feeling sorry for
themselves.
"Singing your heart out and nobody cares.
Not fun, is it?
You've all heard of pop music?
They think they're so great because they're
'popular'.
But you guys are going to help me change that.
Little Miss Polka.
The Mariachi Sisters.
The Barbershop Boys.
And Jax, the Smooth Jazzer."
"Hey babe."
The Smooth Jazz troll then almost hypnotises
Barb with his laid-back tunes.
"That's enough!
Save it for Queen Poppy."
Which, of course, he does later in the actual
movie with Poppy and Branch.
"I can't feel my face."
Barb's reward for Poppy's capture is also
a little different in this cut version:
"Whoever brings me Queen Poppy and her string,
will be the opening act on my World Destruction
Tour!"
Whereas of that, in the actual movie, Barb
offers the winning bounty hunters a tiny refuge
for their own music.
"I don't know.
It looks pretty tiny."
"You want it or not?"
The sneaky Yodellers also get a different
introduction in this deleted scene:
"If you really want the job done right,
you need a couple of Yodellers.
Ya.
We will find this Queen Poppy..
and we will stop at nothing."
The Yodeller's true identity is still kept
a secret with Hickory and Dickory hiding behind
a pair of beer glasses.
What's also interesting about this deleted
scene is that, instead of Barb using a group
of bounty hunters that only represented less
popular music,
in the final film, DreamWorks also included
K-Pop and Reggaeton trolls because they wanted
to make sure there was more musical diversity
in the film and they're two very popular genres.
In an alternate version of the movie, Poppy
and co were going to meet Hickory before they
arrived at Lonesome Flats, home of the Country
Trolls.
"See a troll.
Just like us."
"I say we steer clear."
"Now Branch we're out here to build bridges.
If we steer clear, how will we make new friends?"
"Yeah, more like making new enemies."
But despite Poppy's enthusiasm, the encounter
with Hickory has a spaghetti western-type
vibe as they all eye each other up suspiciously.
"Hi there, I'm Queen Poppy."
"Queen Poppy?"
"Uh huh, of the Pop Trolls."
"Ah!"
"Oh oh!"
"Yippee-ki-yay."
"Only two legs.
Thought I'd seen everything."
Hickory's comments about Poppy only having
two legs and not four like him
are a hint to his secret identity as he's
also really just a two-legged Yodeller troll
pretending to be a four-legged Country Troll.
To keep up his disguise, Hickory continues
to act distrustful around Poppy.
"Where do you tumbleweeds come from?
I don't take kindly to being ambushed."
"Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
We come in peace.
In fact, er..
I'd like to make a peace offering of...
drumroll please...
cotton candy?"
Remember, that cotton candy is what Poppy
was carrying on Sheila B as a plan to make
friends with Barb in the final film.
"I hope you didn't eat all the cotton candy,
because Barb is gonna love it.
And Poppy's sugary offering finally sweetens
up Hickory when he tries it.
"Cotton...
Candy?
Uh huh!
Well howdy, that's a right tasty treat!
Name's Hickory.
What can I do you for?"
Another song early in the movie that ended
up getting cut took place on the Sheila B
balloon and was going to show Poppy revealing
her plan for saving the Troll kingdom.
"We're going to find other trolls.
All we have to do is come together and embrace
our sameness."
"Woo hoo!
Yes Poppy!"
The original scene for this was storyboarded
by DreamWorks artist Jon Magram and features
Poppy singing to the tune of "Can You Feel
It" by The Jacksons.
It's a fun and zany musical number which shows
how Poppy thinks the solution to Barb's attempt
to take over the world with Rock is to shower
Pop Music uniformity over everyone instead.
The cut scene mixes a dream-like quality with
the look of Poppy's scrap-booking and shows
her blanketing the Troll kingdom with pop
music glitter, sparkles and hearts.
Her eyes and mouth blast out multi-coloured
rays of light over the other trolls, turning
their eyes into hearts and them into a string
of happy pop troll puppets.
Branch, who we know is resistant to some of
Poppy's excessive exuberance, uses one of
his pointy sticks and a rock to smash one
of the hearts Poppy is spreading everywhere,
only for her to stick it back on him where
it expands and smothers him.
The deleted song reveals that Poppy's blind
to just how oppressive her ideas really are
and shows some unflattering parallels between
her and Barb in the way Poppy turns other
trolls into Pop Music zombies, just as Barb
later turns them into Rock Music zombies.
In the end, the filmmakers decided the song
was slowing down the story too much, so it
was cut.
A small deleted scene at the beginning of
the movie saw Cooper having a conversation
with a reflection of himself about whether
he thought he was really from one of the other
Troll tribes.
"Hey you.
Do you think I'm one of these different kind
of trolls?
Come on me, I'm just a reflection.
You have to get on out there and find out.
You're right us.
I have to get out into this wide world and
find out for myself.
I can always count on you me.
Thanks.
That means a lot to me, us."
Although the scene's amusing and reminded
me a little of Disney's original Mary Poppins
movie, the word play is possibly a little
confusing which may be why it ended up being
cut.
However, a snippet of this idea was used in
the final film when Cooper's reflection talks
back to him in a mirage.
"I'm saved!"
"Are you, now?
Cause last I checked, I was a mirage."
When Poppy and her entourage arrive at Symphonyville,
they meet Pennywhistle who tells them all
about the destruction Barb and the Rock Trolls
wreaked on the Classical kingdom.
A deleted scene which was cut for time showed
more of what happened and revealed that Pennywhistle
was actually Symphonyville's security guard.
In the scene, we see how the little tin whistle,
unfortunately, took a short break from her
post just before the Rock Trolls arrived.
Oh time for my union break.
Yay!
Ohh.
A nice little detail in this missing moment
is that we would have seen that Pennywhistle
was a model citizen having repeatedly won
Symphonyville's "Employee of the Month" award.
The deleted scene also showed a full-on battle
between the Classical and Rock Trolls with
the Classical Trolls almost winning.
"Ha, ha, ha.
Ow!
Hit in my eye."
"We have the Classical string!"
"Oh dear."
Another deleted trailer scene shows King Trollex
handing over the Techno String to Queen Barb.
"I'm gonna unite the six strings and destroy
all music.
Except for rock!
So I'm gonna need your string."
And if you look carefully at this cut scene,
you'll see that it would have revealed that
the Techno String was held in Techno Beat
Drop Button,
as the middle blue string he normally has
on his head is now missing.
The scene might have been cut because Techno
Beat Drop Button appears at the end of the
movie with all his strings intact even after
all of the six strings have been destroyed.
In the final film, when the Rock Trolls attack
Vibe City, the Funk Trolls ready themselves
for attack.
"Rock has arrived!"
"It's on!
Prepare for battle!"
But the battle never takes place as the Rock
Trolls cut the power to Vibe City.
However, concept art by Timothy Lamb shows
that originally DreamWorks planned to have
a proper music battle between the Funk Trolls
and the Rock Trolls.
As the fight between the Classical and Rock
Trolls was also deleted, we never got to see
any actual battles between the tribes, and
instead in the final movie Barb and her gang
seem to quickly overwhelm any resistance they
encounter.
Another cut moment revealed in concept art
shows that when Poppy and co were imprisoned
in Lonesome Flats, they were going to discover
the skeleton remains of previous prisoners
inside their jail.
This morbid joke would have fit with the Country
Trolls' somewhat sad and macabre take on life
that we heard in the song "Born To Die".
After Hickory busts Poppy and the gang out
of jail, they end up running off the edge
of a canyon into the river below as they flee
from the Country Trolls.
However, what we didn't get to see in the
final version was this scene of them almost
drowning in the river of yarn.
In the final movie, we just see Poppy and
Branch washed up on the river bank instead.
The only remnant of this original idea which
did make it into the film is Dinkle's vision
of ascending to heaven.
"Welcome home."
"Oh, Mr. Dinkles, you're alive.
For a minute there, I thought you'd kicked
the bucket."
[groans]
And more concept art reveals another cut scene
of Branch saving Poppy, pulling her out of
the river.
The purpose of this drawing was also to figure
out what the Trolls would look like when they're
wet, because there isn't any real water in
the Trolls world as even the water in the
river is designed to resemble shiny gossamer
fabric.
In another deleted scene on the water, we
would have seen Cooper meeting a mysterious
character called "Bridge Fisherman" as he
crossed the river on his quest to find his
Troll tribe.
This furry-looking troll is quite different
from any other trolls in the movie
and if you want to discover more deleted characters
from the film such as the K-Pop boy band,
the Giant Funk Troll King, or the Classical
Cooper trolls,
tap here to watch my Trolls World Tour Deleted
Characters video or follow the link in the
video description.
Link will be here as soon as it's ready.
And if you love the amazing artwork by the
DreamWorks artists featured in this video,
you can discover much more of it in The Art
of Trolls book and their Instagrams.
There's links to those in the video description
below.
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
or songs had been included in the movie?
Leave your thoughts in the comments!
Tap left to learn about all the cool easter
eggs you missed in Trolls World Tour or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, then a like and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!